et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
louis aliot bonjour louis aliot merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis
perpignan ville dont vous êtes le maire
et vous êtes évidemment vice président
du rassemblement national on va
évidemment parler de la campagne des
législatives
louis aliot la campagne des législatives
on a vu les résultats dimanche le
rassemblement national arrive en
troisième position mais derrière
jean-luc mélenchon qui semble désormais
incarner l'opposition à emmanuel macron
est-ce que vous avez échoué à
transformer l'essai de la présidentielle
écoutez monsieur mélenchon n'est que le
porte parole d'une coalition de partis
de gauche il n'est pas tout seul il y a
le parti socialiste il y aller vers il y
a un certain nombre le parti communiste
et d'autres soutiennent donc on peut pas
parler de mélenchon comme s'il était
seul ou alors il faut faire l'addition
aux présidentielles et aux dernières
législatives de tout ce qu'il représente
et quand on regarde les scores
additionnés et bien aujourd'hui monsieur
mélenchon il fait moins que la même
coalition la dernière fois aux élections
législatives donc je pense que les
indications
à peu près la même chose monde migrants
elle mais on est sûr de la wii sauf que
nous on progresse par rapport à 2010 est
hélas personne évidemment en tout cas
dans les médias ne le dit pas ce qu'il y
a une espèce de fanfare médiatique qui a
fait la part belle à monsieur mélenchon
même le csa enfin l'art comme a dit
qu'il avait eu beaucoup trop de temps de
parole par rapport à d'autres et on voit
bien un peu vert qui penche aujourd'hui
le système politico médiatique mais peu
importe l'essentiel c'est le terrain ce
sont les électeurs est en tout cas pour
ce qui nous concerne je pense que nos
résultats sont très acceptables il faut
les accentué au deuxième tour pour nous
permettre d'avoir un maximum de députés
à l'assemblée nationale alors on le dira
louis aliot on n'a pas de problème à
dire effectivement vous avez progressé
en nombre de voix vous êtes bien parti
pour avoir un groupe dans la prochaine
assemblée nationale ce serait la
première fois avec un scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours mais quand même
est-ce que du coup vous n'avez pas des
regrets sur votre stratégie est ce que
vous n'êtes pas parti un peu petit bras
quand marine le pen dit au début de
cette campagne des législatives de toute
façon emmanuel macron règne majorité
non je ne crois pas il faut être vous
savez nous on respecte aussi les
institutions et on essaye de dire est la
vérité à nos électeurs on a perdu cette
élection présidentielle mais en faisant
un score remarquable de 43 pour ça et on
citerait millet très bien qu'il y ait un
gros différentiel entre la
présidentielle et les élections
législatives
tout le monde le sait depuis le début de
la vème république or monsieur mélenchon
mans d'ailleurs madame le borgne hier a
dit que c'était le plus grand menteur
parce qu'évidemment il n'a aucune chance
d'être premier ministre il a fait croire
à un électorat que c'était possible
aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait que
c'est impossible et que le vote en
faveur des candidats de mélenchon ne
sert plus à rien il y aura plusieurs
groupes de division à l'assemblée à
gauche mais lui aujourd'hui d'abord ne
sera pas élu et de mai ne sera pas
premier ministre et donc c'est une
entreprise vesle en revanche je pense
que face à la politique de monsieur
macro il faut des femmes et des hommes
j'allais dire neuf qui défendent un
certain nombre de valeurs de tradition
une certaine idée de la politique et je
ne vois aujourd'hui que les les
candidats du rassemblement national pour
le faire parce qu'en matière de pouvoir
d'achat en matière de plus de lutte
contre la précarité sociale de lutte
contre l'ultralibéralisme européens pour
lutter contre l'immigration et
l'insécurité
je ne vois pas qui d'autre peut pas
voter mélenchon et croire qu'on est en
sécurité alors qu'il veut désarmer la
police il ya des contradictions majeures
et je pense que les électeurs au
deuxième tour vont un peu rétablir les
choses et vont nous permettre de peser à
l'assemblée nationale il employait
exactement les mêmes donc vous hier
louis aliot jean luc mélenchon était
invité du 20 heures de france 2 il a dit
votez marine le pen ne sert à rien
qu'est ce que vous répondez
d'écouté mêlant chants étaient trente
ans sénateur socialiste
il a été géré dira ministre socialiste
il a servi à quoi est-ce que depuis que
monsieur mélenchon fait de la politique
les classes ouvrières ont bénéficié de
quoi que ce soit 0 cet homme est un
imposteur
cet homme utilise la violence comme
politique contre la police contre
l'ombre contre la république il est
toujours du côté des voyous et on voit
bien qu'il va chercher aujourd'hui le
vote des banlieues parce qu'il croit que
ça va lui permettre de faire élire
quelques députés de plus mais personne
n'est dupe c'est un communautariste
indigéniste qui est capable de tout pour
arriver il est un formidable
opportuniste pour lui à titre personnel
tout va bien la france il s'en moque la
vérité c'est celle là se pose la
question des reports de voix et de
l'attitude qu'auront les candidats
éliminés notamment au cas de duel entre
la nuque entre jean luc mélenchon et les
candidats du rassemblement national
gérard larcher le président du sénat a
pu bien communiquer hier pour lui
l'annuelle rassemblement national on
présente le même danger pour le pays
qu'en pensez vous
j'en pense que monsieur larcher fait
partie de l'ancien système qui a conduit
la france à la faillite et que ce qu'il
vit malheureusement importe peu et que
comparer les extrémistes de gauche les
trotskistes et tous ceux qui ont conduit
la france dans la ruine tels que le
ministre mélenchon avec les candidats
dur le national ne rime à rien voilà le
problème c'est que monsieur larcher
essayent de cacher partout en france le
nombre de ses amis qui appelle à voter
pour l'extrême gauche contre nous
aujourd'hui et que cette droite et dans
la collusion avec la gauche pour
maintenir un petit système de privilèges
au détriment de l'intérêt général c'est
la seule certitude de cette élection et
je pense que les électeurs ne sont pas
dupes heureusement dans mon département
par exemple dans les pyrénées-orientales
et à perpignan la droite aujourd'hui
j'allais dire parce que elle a renié un
certain nombre de valeurs est réduite à
sa portion congrue
alors qu'on sait très bien que
l'électorat lui répondre à un certain
nombre de réflexes et notamment des
réflexe patriotique c'est la droite
c'est lé cadre de cette droite-là qui
ont conduit à cette situation et je
pense que monsieur larcher et tous les
cadres aujourd'hui dlr sont aujourd'hui
je vais dire des has been de la
politique évent j'espère laisser place à
d'autres pour une recomposition
politique qui permettra enfin de
défendre des valeurs et de défendre un
programme qui permette à la france une
certaine renaissance ils sont vraiment
effacer les républicains aujourd'hui
nous allions dans les projections il
pourrait avoir deux fois plus de députés
que vous est-ce que vous n'allez pas un
peu vite en besogne en présidant leurs
emprunts en prédisant leur effacement
non parce qu'ils ont dans certaines
régions un enracinement certain mais il
ya d'autres régions où ils sont en voie
de disparition
parce que si vous voulez leur attitude
ne correspond pas à leur politique et le
problème c'est qu'on pourrait dire le
fait qu'il sent pêche de 10 ce qui ne
serait ce que de discuter avec nous par
exemple vous avez si l'ancien maire lr
qui se voulait de la droite dure et de
la droite forte qui aujourd'hui dans un
duel contre l'extrême gauche appellent à
voter blanc ce qui est absolument
incroyable qui prouve bien que ces gens
sont à l'origine de l'état de la france
dans lequel nous sommes par manque de
conviction par manque de courage par
lâcheté s'il avait défendu les valeurs
patriotiques
s'il avait lutté contre l'immigration ou
contre l'insécurité nous n'en serions
pas là vous les avez vous est ce que
vous appelez les républicains est ce que
vous appelez les élus républicains vont
rejoindre aujourd'hui est ce
qu'aujourd'hui dans votre région par
exemple ou discuter avec des
républicains ont pas
mais on discute avec des républicains
qui ont le courage de nous répondre
parce que le poulet pour la plupart ils
veulent bien discuter en dehors ou dans
les couloirs mais vous en aurez aucun
devant votre caméra qui vous dira
dimanche j'irai voter pour le candidat
du fn même s'il le fait en revanche dans
les rues vous voyez plein de deux
personnes qui ont voté anciennement
républicaine qui votent encore aux
républicains et qui nous disent on se
trompe fera pas dimanche contre
l'extrême gauche sont contre la
république en marche contre les
candidats de maquereaux nous irons voter
pour les candidats du rassemblement
national parce que eux ont des
convictions eux n'ont jamais changé
d'opinion et vous avez les anciens du
rpr ou même de l'udf qui ne se trompe
pas c'est les cadres qui ont tué ses
idées ce ne sont pas les électeurs qui
sont toujours là et qu'ils continuent à
voter et qui change j'allais dire au fur
et à mesure des élections et se
reportent de plus en plus vers une
caverne vers d'autres formations
politiques pour venir à ces consignes de
vote entre guillemets vous parliez de
celle des républicains dont certains
appellent à faire barrage au
rassemblement national c'est ce que dit
également la majorité présidentielle pas
une voix ne doit aller à l'extrême
droite c'est aussi le moddeur de la
majorité ce que finalement ce n'est pas
l'échec total de votre dédiabolisation
non mais c'est pas nos adversaires qui
font
la diabolisation pas la diabolisation ce
sont les électeurs et écouter à
perpignan on a réussi à gagner à la main
et les électeurs ont su dépasser ses
messages de peur tout le monde sait bien
que nous ne sommes pas à l'extrême
droite car l'extrême droite en france
elle est résiduel elle doit peser deux
ou trois pour cent à tout casser en
revanche on sait où l extrême gauche et
où sont les dangers aujourd'hui du
communautarisme des l'indigénisme duo
qu'ils mais de tout ce qui est en train
de déconstruire la france et cela ça a
pas l'air de gêner un certain nombre de
candidats marche mais je leur dis
attention parce que si demain vous avez
monsieur mélenchon au pouvoir c'est vous
les premiers qui en paierait les
conséquences et c'est malheureusement
les citoyens avec tempérant les
conséquences donc il ne faut pas se
tromper de combat moi je demande le
soutien sûrement pas de la république à
marche ou de personnes mais je dis aux
électeurs réfléchissez bien voilà vous
avez l'état des forces politiques
monsieur macro aujourd'hui est en
difficulté il n'aura pas une majorité
absolue monsieur mélenchon ne sera pas
premier ministre et le vote mélenchon
est inutile vous avez la chance de
pouvoir porter à l'assemblée un groupe
d'opposition sur deux une vraie
politique de vraies valeurs qui
défendront votre quotidien et votre
pouvoir d'achat il faut pas hésiter une
seule seconde tout le reste c'est agiter
des chiffons rouges de la peur qui sont
absolument sans commune mesure avec la
réalité de ce que nous représentons une
force politique républicaine nationale
et patriotes et on n'a pas de leçon de
républicanisme à recevoir de ces gens là
mais pour aller jusqu'au bout de votre
logique du coup louis aliot puisque vous
dénoncez le danger de l'extrême gauche
qu'est pour vous jean luc mélenchon en
tout dans un duel entre la nuque et
emmanuel macron que voter vous
la plupart du temps on votera blanc
parce que à l'arrivée vous savez c'est
monsieur mélenchon qui a plombé monsieur
macron au pouvoir la plupart du temps
c'est quoi ça veut dire quoi la plupart
du temps qui a des cas vous voterez pour
l'un ou pour l'autre
mais ça va venir que ya des cas où notre
électorat va s'interroger par exemple
contre monsieur castaner je pense
effectivement qu'il ya des électeurs du
rassemblement national dans son dans sa
circonscription qui vont réfléchir à
deux fois qui peut être même en se
bouchant le nez iront voter contre
monsieur castaner pourquoi pour et
spécifiquement messieurs castaner
parce que ça a été le pire le pire au
ministre de l'intérieur l'homme le plus
arrogant le plus sectaire il est un peu
l'emblème de ce que représente le
système macro ni en france à la fois
incompétent insignifiant et arrogant ce
que ne veulent plus les français
aujourd'hui aux affaires mais cela veut
dire que vous dénoncez jean luc
mélenchon vous dénoncer les dangers
qu'il peut représenter pour le pays mais
dans le même temps vous préfériez voter
pour un candidat
la nuque plutôt pour un candidat de
d'emmanuel macron c'est ça non non je
dis d'un jeudi dans certains cas moi je
pense que ce soit monsieur macro avec sa
politique ultra libérale qui va encore
socialement faire des dégâts et qui va
laisser encore une immigration
supplémentaires s'installer chez nous et
monsieur mélenchon qui était j'allais
dire
révolutionnaire en ce sens que il veut
l'anarchie il veut le désordre il est
toujours contre la police contre l'armée
contre la justice parce que il veut le
chaos pour permettre à ces idées de
progresser je pense que c'est ni les uns
ni les autres mais il est évident que
sur 577 circonscriptions
il ya des cas particuliers et que
monsieur castaner fait partie de ce cas
particulier de cette exception qui
confirme la règle de ne voter ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres il y en a
d'autres
non je ne sais pas si c'est lui qui
m'est venu à l'esprit parce que je dois
dire qu'il est quand même la caricature
de ce que la macro ni fait de pires un
lui aliot l'abstention a été très forte
dimanche c'est ce qu'elle va vous coûter
des sièges dimanche prochain
ah ben je pense que si l'abstention est
très forte oui c'est pour cela que nos
électeurs doivent se mobiliser peut-être
ne sont-ils pas allés au premier tour en
pensant que la sphère été fait mais là
nous avons plus de 200 second tour ils
ont la possibilité de donner à leurs
idées une juste représentation au
parlement il faut qu'ils aillent voter
le droit de vote est aussi un devoir du
citoyen une obligation du patriote parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer à protester
contre tout si le dimanche si on ne
prend pas un quart d'heure allez mettre
un bulletin rassemblement national dans
l'urne ça ne rime à rien et c'est le
chaos assuré et c'est un chèque en blanc
à la politique de monsieur macron alors
que tous ceux qui ne veulent pas la
politique de monsieur macro tous ceux
qui en ont marre du communautarisme de
l'immigration de 7 ans de cette
insécurité endémique qui pullulent dans
nos rues et bien fassent l'effort de
perdre un quart d'heure de leur dimanche
pour aller voter voilà et votez bien
c'est voter pour le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui c'est une évidence
les autres tous étaient au pouvoir y
compris monsieur mélenchon et le
résultat on a sous les yeux alors qu'ils
ne se trompent pas de bulletin dimanche
c'est essentiel pour le pluralisme pour
la démocratie mais aussi pour nos
libertés dans un communiqué hier soir
eric zemmour dit faire confiance à ses
électeurs pour s'opposer aux politiques
des manuels macro et jean luc mélenchon
mais il n'appelle pas clairement à voter
pour le rassemblement national est ce
que vous regrettez de ne pas avoir
réussi à faire cette alliance avec un
examen
non je pense qu'il a tout à fait raison
les électeurs sont des citoyens libres
ils ont une conscience politique donc
une intelligence politique et je pense
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
consignes comme ça de deuxième tour ne
mène à rien ils feront ce qu'ils veulent
mais on est quand même de nature à
penser que les électeurs qui ont voté
eric zemmour ce en plus enclins à voter
pour nous que pour d'autres mais on
verra bien et je trouve que cette
attitude est une et à une attitude
responsable est ce que la défaite des
règlements au premier tour et celle de
ses principaux lieutenants vous réjouit
elle me réjouis pas mais elle donne une
grande leçon en politique l'arrogance ne
paie pas il ne faut jamais se moquer de
ses adversaires politiques faut toujours
les respecter la démocratie c'est pas
seulement le combat des idées c'est
aussi le respect de ses adversaires
politiques et c'est effectivement le
débat d idées et dans ce débat des idées
on peut dire un certain nombre de choses
mais tout ce qui est caricatural tout ce
qui est excessif est tout ce qui est
j'allais dire qui dénote une certaine
arrogance de comportement ne plaît pas à
l'électeur ne plaît pas à l'électorat
est ce que je reproche le plus un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont mes
anciens amis c'est d'avoir fait quand
même une erreur historique alors qu'ils
auraient pu défendre les mêmes idées
avec nous en tout cas des idées proches
eh bien ils sont allés tenter la
division au risque de faire passer
monsieur mélenchon au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle et ça je dois
dire qu'à titre personnel j'ai du mal à
l'accepter mais justement est ce qu'eric
zemmour et reconquête a encore un avenir
politique selon vous est-ce que cet
avenir il pourrait s'écrire à vos côtés
écoutez je n'en sais rien on partage un
certain nombre de choses ensemble il y
en a d'autres qui nous sépare et d'une
manière significative donc on verra
l'avenir et on verra la manière dont ils
gèrent eux mêmes leur socle électoral
d'aujourd'hui mais pour les sens on est
concentré sur ce deuxième tour des
élections législatives et je pense que
l'heure est là à la mobilisation et à
dire à nos abstentionnistes et à tous
ceux qui ont voté pour marine et qui
sont pas allés au premier tour delà de
la législative aller voter au deuxième
tour c'est essentiel pour vos idées
c'est essentiel pour la france et on
compte sur vous dimanche prochain
puisqu'on parle d'avenir un mot sur
l'avenir de votre parti louis aliot est
ce que vous êtes candidat à la
présidence du rassemblement national
c'est pas une question que je me pose là
aujourd'hui en pleines élections
législatives
on verra ce que marine décide à l'issue
de ces élections législatives est-ce
qu'elle consacrait la main pour andy dat
ass a su si elle passe la main c'est une
question que je me poserai mais vous
savez en discutera entre amis on en
discutera avec jordan bardella
que l'ensemble des membres du bureau
exécutif ce sont des décisions qu'il
faut prendre collectivement mais la
démocratie et le débat d'idées au sein
d'un parti est plutôt salutaire c'est le
c'est plutôt le monolithisme et
l'unilatéralisme qui fait du mal aux
partis politiques mais le débat lui il
est sain il était heureux de voir existe
encore des partis politiques où on est
libre de dire ce qu'on pense et ce que
les lignes de jarden bardet leïla votre
grille et lyon
vous savez moi je commence à être un
ancien dans le rassemblement national et
jordan est un brillant un brillant jeune
de la nouvelle génération donc je n'ai
pas de différence majeure avec jordan
bardella ou alors à la marge donc qui
n'est pas sur une ligne plus identitaire
est ce qu'il n'est pas sur une crise
identitaire là où marine le pen est sur
une ligne social
ben justement c'est une ligne de crête
qu'il faut trouver entre l'homme et
l'autre et c'est précisément ce que nous
nous astreignons affaires depuis
maintenant 2010 avec marine et qu'elle a
très bien réussi et je pense est là que
la grande victoire de marine aujourd'hui
c'est celle là c'est d'avoir su allier
une défense raisonnable de l'identité en
luttant contre tous les excès de
l'immigration du communautarisme et des
atteintes à la laïcité et puis aussi
d'avoir une dimension de solidarité une
dimension sociale qui permettent de
parler à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
et qui remit un certain nombre de choses
en place pour lutter contre les
inégalités qui sont la plupart du temps
dictée par un système mondial
mondialiste et européen qui est en train
de ruiner la france son agriculture ses
services publics et qui a déjà ruiné son
industrie merci louis aliot merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin depuis votre ville de perpignan
merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]